they've solved the most bizarre crimes
imaginable but can Mulder and Scully
figure out baseball the truth is out
there and these iconic moments will have
you believing in more than aliens the
postmodern Prometheus is generally
considered one of the best episodes of
The X-Files for good reason in this
episode we follow Mulder and Scully as
they travel to a small town in search of
a supposed monster who has a strange
fascination with Cher in a modern
retelling of Frankenstein they learned
that the creature was created by a mad
scientist and that the monster is not so
monstrous after all the entire episode
is filmed in black and white giving it a
distinctly old-school horror feel it's
certainly a unique episode and it
concludes with a very sweet Mulder and
Scully moment Scully and Mulder bring
the creature to a bar in town where a
share impersonator performs Walking in
Memphis as the creature gets up to dance
so does Mulder pulling Skully with him
according to Creator Chris Carter the
moment was actually improvised by
Jillian Anderson and David Duchovny it's
an adorable gesture and a rare moment of
cheeriness for the duo there's also
naturalness to their movements that
reveals how comfortable they are with
each other perhaps this is not the first
time they've danced together there are
plenty of physically affectionate
moments like these peppered throughout
the series before they even share their
first kiss and their easy intimacy is
one of the things we love about them
Mulder and scully's relationship doesn't
exactly follow a typical timeline which
is why it can be somewhat surprising
when you map out various Milestones over
the course of the series for example it
isn't until season six that either of
them say I love you and we only see
these words exchanged between the pair
one time in Triangle Mulder finds
himself trapped aboard a World War II
ship that is stuck in 1939 he winds up
surrounded by a disbelieving crew and
attacking SS horses at the very start of
the war he also made some alternate
version of Scully who he tries to
convince to help him but then gets a a
little frisky in case you never meet
again
old Skully responds by punching him in
the face later Mulder wakes up in a
hospital surrounded by Scully Skinner
and the lone gunman none of them believe
his story of course and when Scully
tries to leave Mulder stops her they
look into each other's eyes for long
seconds as sentimental music plays
I love you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
it's a perfectly absurd love confession
for a couple that's anything but normal
and we wouldn't have it any other way
Mulder and Scully are the king and queen
of intimate touches and no form of
intimacy is more Central to their
relationship than the forehead kiss
because of their height difference
Mulder is most often the one doing the
forehead kissing but there are a few
significant reversals to this
arrangement in the sixth Extinction 2
amorfati Mulder spends much of the
episode living in an alternate reality
where he is reunited with his sister and
able to settle down and have a family in
reality the cigarette smoking man is
preparing to harvest a portion of his
brain Scully convinces him to wake up a
week later she shows up at Mulder's
apartment and is shocked to find he is
getting ready to go to work Scully
confesses to Mulder that she doesn't
know who to trust anymore and tearfully
tells him that his ex-girlfriend Diana
Foley to whom he was married in his
dream world has been killed Mulder tells
Scully that even when he didn't know
what was real she was his constant
Scully then kisses Mulder on his
bandaged forehead a touching moment
where they're both able to comfort each
other and it also reveals the depth of
the trust they have in one another
Scully and Mulder are far from a typical
couple and their journey into Parenthood
is similarly unusual Scully becomes
pregnant and everyone naturally assumes
Mulder is the father as we learn in
season 11 the cigarette smoking man is
actually the biological father but for
all intents and purposes Mulder is the
father of Skully's child she names him
after Mulder's father after all as
happens with every new development in
their relationship Mulder and scully's
foray into Parenthood is very natural
nothing really changes about their
relationship because they've always been
in love our favorite moment in this new
chapter is when Mulder meets scully's
baby for the first time they discuss
what a miracle William is but also their
fears about what he is and why he exists
but Mulder suggests that what they
really fear is the truth they both know
it's a typically ambiguous comment and
when Scully asks Mulder what truth he's
talking about he kisses her in response
it's one of the most domestic moments
the pair have on the series and
considering what they've both been
through quietly settling down is
something they both deserve the season 7
episode all things is an important
X-Files episode for several reasons and
one of them is that it was written and
directed by Jillian Anderson it's also
important to fans because it's heavily
implied that Mulder and Scully sleep
together in this episode all things
follow Scully on her quest to save a
doctor she dated in medical school it's
a very spiritual reflective episode and
much of it focuses on scully's past but
it also contains a classic Scully and
molder moment that is utterly perfect in
its Simplicity Scully returns from her
solo Mission and she and Mulder have an
existential conversation on the couch
discussing how every choice they've ever
made has led them to where they are
right now Mulder might be content to
have the discussion all night but Scully
falls asleep mid-sentence in response
Mulder carefully brushes her hair out of
her face and covers her with a blanket
it's often the quietest moments like
these between Mulder and Scully that are
the most meaningful the episode begins
with Scully getting ready in the
bathroom and Mulder in bed a fairly
obvious indication they did more than
just talk on the couch that night
do you have a theory I have plenty of
theories Mulder and Scully have
exchanged some beautiful words over
their 11 Seasons but there's one
exchange between them that takes the
cake Folia do is one of the best and
most disturbing episodes of The X-Files
and it contains one of the all-time best
Boulder and Scully moments in this
episode the pair are sent to investigate
a man who claims his boss is a giant bug
monster as usual at first Scully
struggles to believe Mulder's account
laying in the hospital bed Mulder
implores Scully to check for evidence
proving his claims he tells her she has
to believe him because no one ever does
[Music]
you're my one and
five billion
Scully eventually finds evidence that
corroborates what he saw but whether or
not the FBI knows the truth is
irrelevant the fact that she was willing
to believe him is all that matters to
Mulder and this trust between them is
the foundation of their relationship
Mulder has proven both with his words
and his actions that he cares about
Scully more than anything else in the
world and it's this unshakable bond
between them that makes it absolutely
clear that they belong together
Mulder and Scully shippers are a patient
Bunch it took seven seasons for Scully
and Mulder to have their first kiss for
a show full of outlandish twists and
turns it might come as a surprise that
Mulder and scully's first kiss is so
ordinary but that's also the beauty of
their relationship for all the
ridiculous and life-or-death situations
they find themselves in the fact that
they love each other has never been a
part of the problem that's the easy part
season 7 episode 4 takes place on New
Year's Eve and is aptly titled
Millennium the episode ends with Scully
and Mulder watching the ball drop on TV
the clock strikes midnight and Scully
and Mulder look at one another as if the
decision is the most obvious thing in
the world as the music swells they lean
in for a kiss that lasts a full 10
seconds neither of them seems at all
shocked by this development and nothing
really changes between them either
it's a little bit man no didn't
Mulder is probably referring to the fact
that some people thought the Millennium
spelled the end of humanity but we kind
of like the idea that he's talking about
their kiss
Scully experiences a huge number of
hardships over the course of the series
and one of the most trying events in her
life was her battle with cancer in
season four in Memento Mori Scully
discovers she has inoperable cancer and
that all the other women with symptoms
similar to hers have died near the end
of the episode Mulder finds Scully in
the hallway of the hospital having gone
looking for her when he didn't find her
in her room though she is terrified of
what's to come Scully tells Mulder she
won't let it beat her they hug in the
hallway
the truthful
Ness I think it'll save both of us
the physical intimacy of this moment is
touching but so is Mulder's unshakable
confidence in Scully he's also terrified
of what might happen to her but he never
stops believing in her ability to find
the answers they're both looking for
While most of the memorable Scully and
Mulder moments occur within the series
itself there is one scene worth
mentioning from the 1998 movie The
X-Files fight The Future Mulder and
Scully get into a fight in the hallway
and Scully expresses how guilty she
feels about what's happened to Moulder
her partner is quick to dissuade that
line of thinking emphasizing how many
times she saved him
I owe you everything
calling you owe me nothing
Skully cries they hug and then Scully
gives Mulder another one of their
patented forehead kisses then comes a
moment we thought we'd never see Scully
and Mulder lean in for a kiss but they
are rudely interrupted by a bee that
stings scully's neck it's almost rude
the way fans were teased by the almost
kiss but we also kind of love how drawn
out their relationship is and how so
many of their most intimate moments
presumably happen just off screen
Duchovny and Anderson actually filmed a
version of that scene that ended in a
very heated kiss but it didn't make the
final cut executive producer Frank
spotnitz told the Huffington Post he was
in the theater when fans reacted to the
almost kiss and hearing those screaming
fans Remains the highlight of his time
working on the show
some of the most touching moments
between Mulder and Scully occur when one
of them is injured or otherwise
incapacitated but we have a soft spot
for the Times where they just get to
relax and have fun together season 6
episode 19 tells the story of an alien
who crash-landed in Roswell in the 1940s
and wanted nothing more than to play
baseball so he joined a team there
considering the episode is all about
baseball an odd topic for a show about
aliens it's only right that it ends with
a sporty moment Scully meets Mulder at
the baseball field responding to the
Urgent Message he left for her Scully
derisively describes baseball as a waste
of time which Mulder takes offense to in
the end he convinces her to come play
positioning the bat in her hands and
reaching from behind her to show her how
to swing it Scully quickly gets over her
aversion to the sport laughing and
following Mulder's humorous instructions
she tells him
shut up mother I'm playing baseball it's
one of the most joyful moments in the
entire X-Files timeline and you can
almost imagine that Scully and Mulder
are just a typical couple in love with
no existential worries on the horizon we
almost wish that were the case but then
they wouldn't be Scully and molder would
they
[Music]